all right now welcome to new video for a
change I do a quick warzone video here
two minute games continued on the theory
serious only 45 tomorrow I guess it's
the preparing something for for the next
video edit this is not quite finished
but I'd like to upload something today
so I'm going for this quick tourney here
let's see what happens I'll try to play
aggressively with white trying to maybe
get in quicker wins then with my usual
t4 stuff not sure that this was really
aggressive enough but okay let's see
what happens got an Italian game and I'm
trying to g5 so quite surprising from
black I will go Knight f5 next hmm yeah
should be fine
no I could try to get some play going
here but his he's going for my deform
but I can just take on G 5 H 5 is a no
and also a 7 so needs to do some forcing
move now neither for just caption
yeah now I can take on f7 or yeah why
not
I'm also threatening route g1 stuff like
that
I haven't cancelled of course so look
wait I have to structure one okay is
some getting some counter tick here so
the Sun should be fine now I can go rook
g6 attack h6 it doesn't even try to
defend this not sure that it was
possible but it should be a simple win
now
Quincy form threatening Queen g6
checkmate he doesn't have a move really
yeah I can take this still left the
bishop here yep
this wasn't terribly quick but at least
I think quite convincing okay
all right some some quiet um good
players in here this is a 30 minute
tournament with two-minute games right
let's see I hope I don't have any
non-google Sloan resigned us and so on
the center game may be a gambit line
will see three yeah I usually decline
this it's a simple approach that usually
I'm like is oh this is unusual
hmm what if I just go in there that's
some problem okay I couldn't think take
maybe I could have taken even yeah I'm
not sure what this move is doing I can
just play b5 if everything else fails
but what about c6 and threatening Bishop
c3 also he might go Bishop d2 the okay
let's let's play it simple he now needs
to return to the one okay he doesn't
think he needs to return his get he's
got this one maybe but I can just take
all this stuff here hmm
yeah maybe he's got some brilliant idea
okay might get some stuff back what is
that it doesn't have any left it doesn't
even have a check here
he's got rook e1 check
I can go give this check also
okay let's just grab the stuff okay I
can even go to d7 here I don't see
anything why I shouldn't okay I take now
here he might take here maybe this one
threatening Quincey to checkmate I'm
down to 19 seconds great it's this is of
course always an issue with these crab
gambits their ultimate ly just incorrect
but sternly to refute it
yeah mate was necessary here I was down
three 11 seconds and I'm not quite sure
if this was correct but okay it worked
out okay two two two something player
here so I play play aggressive stuff
this is unusual meaning combined with
this here
can i play this sometimes it's possible
with without these moves of course this
is somewhat different but ok but it's
not really a super important game here
so let's just try this not quite sure if
he's got something maybe he's got
something concrete here technically
mmm okay it's got quite some pressure
here so maybe need to need to take this
off
yeah how to tell them that my king
should go when Cassidy has got night a2
also mm Matt looks very shaky here try
to get the king to g3 of course
something like Queen b6 but yeah we can
grab the spawn now if he wants don't
think it should be should be great now
my king position is very young very weak
yeah could could be a good move
nurse losses necessarily on e5 5400 what
try to try to keep this closed
yeah I simply have no time just played
far too slowly here I queen queen afore
yeah I was just far too slow yeah not
quite sure the position know what was
too complicated to judge really all
right
quite quite some points down here
compared to first place okay
maybe I can initiate some quick attack
here but let's hope to this okay at
least his weakening asking side I'm
going for a long castle and then h5
opening up lines yeah okay f6 was a move
I wanted to make anyway so no problem
yeah I can also just scrap you form but
h5 should be a good move
yeah let's go f5 maybe f5 I could have
taken here all the time but want to get
to get to the king quickly
now into second the point to open up the
King not quite sure if it's correct but
should be should be playable that's we
moved and he is preparing and is
preparing this but therefore f3 is
hanging now okay coming close to the
king
I can play this now it takes rook F 2 is
checkmate in a couple of moves
I made next move okay not hopelessly
behind but the two kind of strong
opponent going from the panel fatigue
here fairly typical isolated poor
position
okay
yeah okay maybe I can go for c-45 - to
weaken this Knights position okay still
cannot take because the singers hanging
and if I play the yeah it's very cool
but he cannot miss this Knight made on
aged seven yeah this is just a piece
okay but it's not so easy technically at
least it looks a bit tricky at first
maybe 9595 trying to force him to take
himself on c1 so that I have rook c7
okay it doesn't take but one okay Roxy
soon
can also maybe just play this this one
here securing the position here this
rook doesn't have a lot of squares if I
go here well it's it's just the same
every time
he's just playing on time blundering all
his stuff but trying to be quick
there's a checkmate if he takes root G 7
h 7 g7 made and she can just give a
check here
but now f7 is saying I hope that this is
just finishes in a quick attack now
okay he's some having some counter play
ideas and it will try to win by meteor
because of the time group which is 7 now
threatened not sure if he is anything
just maybe desperado Secchia just
returned okay let's just get the H point
in okay for for the long time yeah look
quite decent only wasn't too quick
2017 plan let's see what we get here
first try to get the sharpest stuff
going here okay
th6
maybe you can even take here c4 I can
wrap this I take her but I can I can
just take okay no problem
no maybe we should def 5 to check I can
just answer with g6 they cannot Castle I
know this yeah this looks fine
no B should be for I know p8 okay
non castle I can just take yeah this
looks difficult for white yeah well
maybe just just here threatening on be
to take now but I can just retreat right
it's still hanging you cannot cover be
to really overthrew see - I'm with
similar would be one and of course the
check so he cannot okay let's grab it
and this one is alright how do i ended
up quickly c5 yeah just like is this is
correct me to open up as many lines as
possible if he grabs rook inform with
the idea of group c4 mate
try to finish this now not in an endgame
orders checkmate okay
okay let's try to play aggressive him
oops
Bishop d3 it was close okay and now I
hope for f5 Bishop h6 this kind of
attack okay you prevented this okay King
let's close it up
what what can you do hmmm so much for
the quick medium of course strategically
this position is very nice the knight to
c5 oops I could have just taken the
bishop I was so focused on getting the
night there that I just played it
immediately okay it's still pretty nice
position of course they cannot really
are too much
he tries to open up the the G fall a
ticking c7 okay maybe I can can open it
up him myself shouldn't be so bad
alright come on this looks now I'm
getting this rope to f6 yeah this isn't
a quick win as I hope but in quite nice
position this can be some sort of
stalemate
awesome strong position because he will
run out of moves at some point
okay but what do I do next
just grab the spawn
damn it once the disposal I wanted to
say as far as possible but even Lord
allowed me to advance it even further
okay and it's checked now just are just
this one if I promote he has a check so
I need to learn Oh rugby 656 oops okay
okay I can promote next move I think
we had this took far too long to catch
up in the tournament really okay just
six minutes left
yeah some possible to catch up here okay
scotch game that's trying to open it up
quickly maybe I can get something on the
on the a on the old file yeah should be
should be at least fine for me if I grab
here threatening checkmate okay one so
cannot take the can't cannot take the
rook just winning a move here willing
attempt over here okay I can I can give
the check
do I have something better mmm okay
let's just keep this look for now maybe
I can go Queen a 8 a 5 or something go
for a direct attack
this ran through k1 check Queen a5 and
taking the bishop with check the spots
the bishop
Roxy eight I can do this right yeah it's
not checkmate only eight you know maybe
I should have played for mate yep
okay with the end game of the extra
piece wins easily of course he doesn't
really resigns this is nice
maybe I have a minimal man for third
place very difficult yeah I just
couldn't afford the one City loss and it
was quite sad to quite long games didn't
get some quick made on why do you think
and of course I got far better position
than the other guys but still
the Karis a dick this looks nice
can I take g7 hmm not quite sure I'm
just threatening 95 okay now I take the
rook here just that's the key let's take
this chump over here oops
okay resides nice fifth place well I
mean I'm five points short of third
place maybe maybe some really quick win
here
yeah I know the Queen exchange but I
have some some ideas um I often want
quickly in this line believe it or not
that's crap to be upon you and there
goes a piece yeah yeah I just went
quickly in this line no idea why but of
course it's just a piece you must
directly ups won't resign it's an extra
look for just nothing and now it's an
opinion one military resigns nice I'm
still not on third place and I need one
more win maybe one more win come on hey
get me a game I need to win in 50
seconds I don't get it cameras
yeah well 50 seconds is quite difficult
of course
yeah the waiting times have been quite
lonesome
okay this win in 30 seconds
yeah this is impossible now win in two
seconds okay okay yeah finished finished
six place and just one game short of
third place yeah
somehow the games took too long and of
course I had this the city last year
with with this g4g for Sicilian which
was not so solid I guess yeah well I
hope it was entertaining anyway yeah
check back for a new video soon and
thanks for watching